real-world objects are fairly
complicated often they're virtual
representations are greatly simplified
when we compare this table model from
Google warehouse to its real-world
counterparts we immediately notice that
many details are missing these details
are what make designing fabrica Ballabh
checks very difficult for casual users
in this work we present a modeling tool
that leverages information from a
collection of fabric oval designs in
order to enable casual users to model
and build real-world objects to allow
structure preserving manipulations we
automatically convert the designs in our
collection to hierarchical parameterize
templates our template model takes into
account global relationships such as
symmetries and articulation
consistencies it is also not restricted
to fix topologies allowing irregular
patterns to be rescaled notice how the
number and position of connectors
changes as the template parameters vary
our modeling tool is based on template
manipulation and composition we allow
users to explore the space of template
variations using different levels of the
template hierarchy during manipulation
active elements of the hierarchy are
shown in full color while other elements
are semi-transparent once a part is
position the user invokes a method that
brings in connecting elements to the
design by exploring the template
database notice how for a wooden table
top corner brackets that automatically
brought in to connect the top to the
legs while for a glass top a whole
support structure for the glass is
automatically added we incorporate in
our system a stability analysis
evaluation there was a user if the
design model isn't stable we illustrate
a full modeling session for composition
refers this is the users by snapping
drag components onto the working model
the user can continue to reposition and
rescale the model until she's satisfied
with the snap configuration
the output of your system is a
comprehensive bill of materials that can
be directly used for fabrication
you
here are some additional results
one of the main advantages of using a
data-driven approach is its generality
notice how the same method that creates
tables and cabinets can also be used on
row cards
you